la parole est à monsieur rémi delattre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le conseil
d'orientation des retraites débat
aujourd'hui de son rapport annuel
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
les chiffres ne sont pas encourageants
le retour à l'équilibré de notre système
de retraites n'aurait pas lieu avant
autant dire que votre loi du 20 janvier
2014 garantissant l'avenir du système de
retraite non garantie d'avenir que dans
son titre
le besoin de financement de l'ensemble
des régimes de retraite pour 2019 et
pour 2020 s'élève en effet à près de 10
milliards d'euros
et pourtant cette loi ne date que d'un
an à peine lors de l'examen de ce texte
nous vous avions fait des propositions
sur l'âge de départ sur la durée de
cotisation or vous les avaient balayés
d'un revers de la main
refusant ainsi de vous inscrire dans une
démarche de long terme à l' inverse de
ce que nous avions fait en 2003 puis en
2010 avec françois fillon
monsieur le premier ministre à l'opposé
des pays qui ont eu le courage d'engager
les réformes
la france décroche l'exemple des
retraites est à cet égard symptomatique
de votre incapacité à réformer notre
système de retraites comme le marché du
travail comme les dépenses publiques
comme la réforme de l'état exige une
réforme structurelle d'ampleur mais sur
ces sujets vous promettez de grandes
annonces
et finalement vous présentez des petites
mesures il est vrai que vous êtes
englué dans de telles querelles de
partis que vous êtes de plus en plus
souvent privé d'une majorité pour
réformer oui monsieur le premier
ministre pour faire face aux grands
enjeux de la france et notamment pour
l'avenir des retraites
allez vous engager de vraies réformes
comme le font nos voisins européens
merci la parole est à madame barrisol
dorel ministre des affaires sociales de
la santé et des droits des femmes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député rémi delattre franchement
la mauvaise foi ne connaît pas de
limites parce que moi je vais vous
rappeler la vérité des chiffres
allez vous rappeler la vérité des
chiffres
s'il vous plaît mon frère bon caractère
en 2010 la vérité des chiffres c'est
qu'en 2010 les régimes généraux le
régime général de vieillesse de caisses
de retraite était en déficit de 6
milliards d'euros que cette année ce
déficit est ramenée à 800 millions
d'euros
c'est la commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale qui l'a annoncé il ya
quelques jours et donc les régimes de
base pour les salariés du privé seront à
l' équilibre dès l'année prochaine dès
2016 ça c'est une certitude qui permet
de rassurer nos concitoyens et je veux
vous dire monsieur le député que plutôt
que d'inquiéter plutôt que d'alarmé vous
devriez vous réjouir que grâce à la
politique qui est menée
le cochon citoyens puissent être
garanties alors monsieur le député au
delà au delà des régimes de base
il reste à rétablir l'équilibré des
régimes complémentaires et cela relève
de la responsabilité des partenaires
sociaux qui sont engagés qui sont
engagés dans une négociation difficile
que nous suivons attentivement et je
suis certaine qu'ils seront capables de
prendre leurs responsabilités alors
monsieur le député plutôt que
d'inquiéter rappeler à nos concitoyens
que dans la durée leur retraite seront
maintenus que grâce aux mesures du
gouvernement le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités est maintenu nous avons
revalorisé à 800 euros par mois
le minimum vieillesse nous avons versé
une prime exceptionnelle de 40 euros
pour les retraites inférieures à vis de
100 euros nous avons revalorisé des
retraites agricoles
monsieur le député nous sommes engagés
pour la justice mais aussi pour la
garantie dans la durée de notre système
de retraite sylla